I thought we're family you know it
really is it's so great to make these
movies have your family it's like a
family get together with everybody shows
up tellement Nally and all the pirate
gang or the black poll that will get
together with some beverages and we
watch either the previous film or all
the film we just want to hear the
handsome ask or we want to we're all
getting old we want to remember what
actually happened that lot and you know
adding new members is great kya and
Brenton are new kids and in the movie
nice romantic story between them and
then Javier Bardem for the commitment to
that character and the way they work is
it's kind of inspiring it to see them
work and to watch them as like you know
it's like you're in the theater watching
a play so it's very educational
it was all really funny to me I hadn't
interested in astronomy of which women
have named consolations and the Stars
and stuff it I don't know what overall
it just was until I was getting called
it I'm a bit of a science bum and I love
the fact that in the 18th century there
is this funky feisty woman who has
aspirations to be a scientist I think
makes it a really kind of heavy meal
I've never been treated like the only
girl which is nice they never made me
feel like that and you know they'd have
the same conversations and the same fart
jokes and same thing they burp around me
and I Burgesses out it's her being
single individual and a groundbreaking
ballbusting woman
Disney in so many movies it's like a
plane's on a runway waiting to take off
we had to wait for all the Marvel movies
and Pixar movies and then Star Wars
we're at the back of the line but we
finally got to the front
you